she's got the same hair as you
eden's birth was a relief after her
brother's traumatic entrance two years
before
when their mother tanuke was rushed into
hospital with a life-threatening
condition
i felt like my pain was dismissed
and i felt like i just wasn't taken
seriously
yes i'm black but i'm still human i'm
still a woman i still bleed the same
blood
um and any assumptions made off of the
back of
the colour of my skin i just think it's
not on
it's why she and a friend set up a
campaign to change this statistic
black women are five times more likely
to die in childbirth
than white unconscious bias it's
it's one reason that black women miss
you know
black women are prone to pain so we can
take more pain
black women skin not in black women
black people in general our skins are
tougher
and all and you know they're strong
black women and all of those are just
myths
they stress it's still very safe for
women to give birth but the reasons
behind the figures
are complex black women are twice and
three times as likely to
deliver a baby that is stillborn they
are more likely to deliver
babies that are underweight and we know
that once that inequity is embedded at
birth
that then will lead to a young female
child that's more likely to have
poorer health conditions gynecological
conditions
that then may render her at greater risk
when she is pregnant
the nhs acknowledge mortality disparity
but with no specific target to end it
and so there's a lack of trust it was a
terrible time actually it was
frightening
deborah's haunted by the possibility her
child grace might have died
she made a choice for her second birth i
needed to
to some extent be around um
i'd say health practitioners that i knew
were similar to me
as hard as it is to say that so yeah
basically that i need i needed to be
around that to give you the confidence
to give me the confidence to know that i
was going to be okay
and amid wider health inequality there's
covid
19. different rates of
cancers and cardiovascular disease and
diabetes
and of course covid19 has had and
continues to have a disproportionate
impact
to be proud of our nhs is not to be
blind to his imperfections
and that's why we are focusing on
tackling these issues
head on change is slow bias isn't always
intentional or easy to pinpoint but it
may well be impacting on life
at the very start adele robinson sky
news